now looking to beyond the earth's
horizon an increasing amount of trash is
orbiting our planet
scientists say the amount of space junk
circling our planet is massive
fast and moving and potentially
dangerous this week european experts are
meeting virtually
to devise new plans on how to deal with
space debris including sending out
a new fleet of orbital trash collectors
earth is slowly being wrapped in a cloud
of debris
experts estimate that nearly 130 million
pieces of scrap
metal are currently orbiting our planet
most are only a few millimeters in size
but there are also tanks rocket stages
and old satellites
because of their high speed even small
fragments have the potential
to cause significant damage as a result
space junk is now being monitored
radar and laser systems can see objects
between
5 and 10 centimeters large they can also
show where the debris is located
if a collision is imminent satellites
and even the space station
can be programmed to change course to
avoid the debris
but dramatic collisions have already
occurred more than once
like in 2009 when a discarded satellite
crashed into a telecommunications
satellite
that was still in use this created a
cloud of
thousands of pieces of debris today this
junk still circles the earth space
debris like this
could cause further collisions leading
to an uncontrollable chain reaction
that's why researchers and engineers
have decided to clean up the trash
in the earth's orbit
[Music]
they want to catch tumbling satellites
with huge nets from a safe distance
like catching fish in the ocean their
goal is to pull the space junk
out of the danger zone researchers have
already conducted
initial tests the european space agency
is working on robotic systems that can
grab
satellites they'll push them towards the
earth until they burn up
in the atmosphere in 2025
scientists will launch clear space 1
a demonstration satellite it will
capture a drifting
100 kilo rocket stage bring it out of
orbit
and burn up with it as they descend to
earth
clear space 1 will be the first step
towards space junk disposal
for more on that we're now joined by tim
flora he's the head of the space debris
office at the european space agency in
darmstadt
here in germany so how soon will those
trash collector robots be ready to get
to work
well everybody clear space one our
technology demonstration as a first of
its kind on
end-to-end removal of an intact object
is
due for launch in 2025 but of course
more has to be done after that this is
just a demonstration
so why is this trash in outer space not
even an outer space and actually
uh um quite close to earth why is this
trash
circling this planet so so dangerous
the issue is the high overall velocity
as you call them so this is the
the speed and the depth the energy that
even tiny objects have when they circle
our planet
even the one centimeter or few
centimeter object with this velocity of
seven and a half kilometers per second
has enough energy to severely damage an
intake
right even to completely destroy it
because the energy is equivalent to the
hand grain
so are we doing this because we can or
is there really a
cost benefit i mean this mission of
trash collection
uh must be very expensive
yes indeed unfortunately we have made
mistakes in the past
we were not good enough in mitigating
the creation of space debris and that's
why explosions and collisions have
happened
and if you ask about it because the risk
is
that we lose the orbital regime as a
resource and think of all
the daily applications we're all using
today in the modern society
that rely on a space-based
infrastructure i'm not only talking
about
stack maps and and weather forecasts i'm
also thinking a bit more hidden things
like
global coordination of trading and
if we would lose this infrastructure
there is no
other orbital regime around our planet
we could not proceed
in the way we are using technology
that's the risk we have to face
tim flora there head of the space debris
office at the european
space agency in darmstadt germany thank
you very much tim
you